[Music]
the jets will be unveiling their new
uniforms tonight someone unveiled the
uniforms for them yesterday and we've
seen this happen before last year the
jaguars uniforms got unveiled because
they put up a giant graphic at the
airport a day early and you know the
closer in time the leak comes to when
they're going to unveil it the more
credible the leak is and there are
plenty of people who say that these
aren't the real uniforms if you're
watching on nbcsn you can see it if
you're listening you just have to take
my word for it it looks convincing if
this is a photoshop job it is one of the
best i've ever seen like why are you
wasting your photoshop skills on making
phony jets uniforms and putting it out
there one day before you're gonna be
proven wrong this is impressive you have
guys standing in the poses they would be
standing in you have the right lighting
the right shading the right logos the
right details the right everything now
the uniforms are ugly in my opinion
maybe we'll get used to them but these
are what these nike uniforms do there's
always a black jersey and black pants
there's always the the name of the city
over top of the numbers that aren't like
the old school block numbers we have to
have different shapes to the numbers
yeah and we have to have the city's name
on there because god forbid we would
think that they are the san antonio jets
but uh but anyway these apparently are
the uniforms chris that will be unveiled
tonight by the jets and the jets
presumably not too pleased that the
uniforms got leaked a day early yeah i
mean i heard that i heard you know chris
johnson yelled at the the staff and all
the people in the front office i mean
what they're they're saying that they
think maybe the leak was not from the
jets and maybe from nike or the nfl or
somebody like that
correct me if i'm wrong there mike but
um i'm with you okay you know i like the
nike uniforms i've liked how they've
made some teams uniforms a little edgier
and different looking certainly but i'm
not always for that for some of the
older traditional teams and i look at
the jets uniforms right now
i don't mind the helmet i'm down with
the helmet with the j-e-t-s across the
board there okay kind of the 80s style
helmet but i'm with you with the rest of
the uniform i'm not so sure i love it uh
maybe it's the different color green uh
in the little stripes in the shoulder
pad whatever it may be i think it is too
edgy or almost college looking for the
nfl i look at mike you know they kind of
look like marshall and the green jerseys
with the white pants i feel like it
looks like marshall other than the
helmet
i've i've seen comparisons to the
saskatchewan rough rides as well now
you're right it's very close i
understand that this was the basic
scheme the helmet
the green helmet with jets in white that
was what they wore from 1978 through
1997 not exactly a stellar area in team
history so i don't know that you want to
pay homage to that but but
the change for the sake of change i
don't get and i said this earlier on the
radio site chris
if i had bought my kids
official sam darnold jerseys the the 300
stitched on letters and numbers for
christmas and three and a half months
later they are rendered irrelevant by an
entirely new uniform design i would not
be happy and that's one of the things
that happens far too often look the
browns have changed their uniforms once
since nike came on board now they're
going to change them again yeah the
jaguars have changed theirs twice since
nike got involved i mean at some point
you got to be a little more sensitive to
your consumer to your customer who has
spent big money on one of these jerseys
and god forbid anyone was dumb enough to
buy a jets jersey over the last three
months because
if you want the jersey the team is
actually going to be wearing this fall
you don't have it anymore no i i that's
a legitimate concern you're right it's
kind of uh unfair to the consumer or at
least the consumer who's not aware that
there's a new jersey release or whatever
it may be but come on we're being a
little nitpicky there hey you're gonna
wear the sam darnold jersey whether it's
last year's version or this year's
version okay yeah whether you go to the
jets game i get it it's part of the
business of the nfl right now the jets
were due for a new fresh look so are the
damn cleveland browns they need
something different i mean i don't know
the browns uniforms are uglier now than
ever i think
i like the way they look back in the 80s
a little bit when it was just simpler or
whatever it may be but i think also
teams look at this as changing the
uniforms mike is like changing the
culture you know a little bit like bill
parcells when he went to new england he
said damn all these red white these red
jerseys with the the patriot on the you
know on the helmet snapping the football
he just associated that with losing and
i think that's why he wanted to change
the look of the uniform and i think
that's what some of these teams like the
jets and jaguars do too they're kind of
trying to change the vibe of their
overall culture and football team
and the best teams never change their
uniforms right the teams that are
relevant year in and year out the teams
that we care about year in and year out
they don't change and they likely never
will but the patriots changed and
started winning the denver broncos
changed and won super bowls there's two
teams that changed
i got you right there
well
i i don't i don't disagree with that
concept but there's still going to be
plenty of bad teams to keep changing
their uniforms every few years
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports